dans l'équipe on a compris deux choses
que vous êtes arrivé dans tp la première
si vous êtes une grande fan de boulettes
et la deuxième votre plus grande
angoisse et les inserts arrête ce soir
j'ai changé en fait maintenant vous
inquiétez pas ce soir mais pas que ce
soir vous allez devoir affronter votre
peur pour faire gagner de l'argent à
l'association les gens de la rue
l'association tient énormément à coeur
une association qui vient en aide aux
sans abri aux familles en difficulté
partout en france depuis de très longues
années
vous allez devoir vous placer sur ce
qu'on appelle notre tête et chercheuse
dans fort boyard il appelle la teneur je
t'en supplie nous cela te tais cherchez
vous inquiétez pas vous n'allez rien
avoir à faire vous ne bougez pas valérie
elle fera le reste
valérie vous allez vous mettre en place
alexandre veuillez mettre en place
valérie avoir un truc de du psg sur ma
bagnole mené par là elle est venue il y
à différents paliers de gamme duo poser
des questions tant que vous n'avez pas
la bonne réponse vous resterez bloqués
ne passerait pas au palier suivant
pallier un millier de 2000 euros à
travailler 3 5 millions d'onces valérie
ma chérie mettez-vous en place avant que
vous mettiez en place on va regarder
ranarivelo mais les insectes et vous
allez voir c'est une grande et belle
mère inquiète tu n'a rien à faire dans
les lecteurs
si vous n'avez pas du tout thème rien
les insectes ça va non
valérie bénaïm et aux attentes ou quasi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'aimez pas du tout j'aime rien
il est certain que ça va
non c'est quoi [ __ ] mais bouge tes 16
médailles dollars mais ce contenu
d'ailleurs nous en font la gueule que
son nom tagab ont été libérés des
messages bombe à l'ailé mais l'animent
bah merci à bayonne
on est 20 mai naim a laissé beaucoup
aidé par sûr
joe di luca mais que des blagues mais je
t'emmerde ballet la loterie colada vous
faire c'est que jean michel maire on l'a
entendu dire ah ah ah waouh je joue bien
la comédie parce que jean-michel mais en
fait je vous explique il est persuadé
que c'est une vanne et que ça n'est pas
la bonne personne mais je vous le jure
c'est vraiment c'est ça et merci dans le
digital avec lui mais il est persuadé
qu'on lui fait une blague hein il est
temps serait vraiment la personne qui
était avec lui dans la diable donc il
n'y crois pas encore il n'est pas légal
il dit je joue bien la commune amer il a
pas compris c'est la vraie personne ça
fait quatre mois du 10e fed mandat
qu'incombait et il m'a dit oui c'est
vraiment la main de fer spot lacombe et
moderne avec une chose incroyable il
nous a dit c'est la web il n'y croit
toujours pas valérie bénaïm ma chérie
d'amour arrête de me dire machinerie
d'amour et brassaï et alors que la fête
commence à se répéter
regardez ce qu'est la bienvenue en
suisse attendait qu est ce qu elle avait
valérie est ce qu'on peut voir des trucs
cette série les croates les mille-pattes
ici dit alors la tension va les faire
paraître tatatata site pour 1000 euros
autour de vous il y à des bulles et
c'est ce que ces cds sorte de
mille-pattes normes
attention à 90 ans explique moi juste
avant parce que ce peuple est là je suis
stressé vas-y vous avez trois paliers
ouais 1000 euros 2000 euros 5000 euros
qu'est ce qui ne vous n'avez pas bien
répondu à la question à ça continue les
murs tombent sont pas créés par ar tango
combien de boîtes à une nulle je vous
dirai plus ou mois c'est parti banal et
tombent ils ont eu nul est là combien de
fois sans patch n'en ont pas mal écran
simonpieri combien ça sans moi moi moi
quatre jours moi je vois pas du tout les
insectes les schémas non moi n'avons
plus plus plus de 380 moi à oui voilà
comme à moi combien attention fermer la
boucle soit chéri attention deuxième
pour 2000 euros en centimètres sur vita
pour aller jusqu'à quelle distance peut
sauter à craquer en cm pour
l'association pas dire attention on va
jouer pour sa meilleure en valeurs
d'état
attention aux joues avec des plates
valérie dans les villes
c'est pas attention valérie pour 5000
euros on le sait une blatte peut vivre
sans tête mais qu'on blinde jours à
prévoir de quoi après voilà quoi il ya
des débats ma présence à quoi des bonnes
choses regardez c'est bon c'est brian
n'a plus rien y employer à bras c'était
des gens tuent personne c'est que des
gentils personnes valérie c'est que des
gentils personne merci aéroport peut
dire l'équipe de production
après que valérie vous avez gagné 5000
euros à l'association travaux pas les
rides amour et valérie voulez je vous
lis tout ce que vous avez vaincu votre
peur non je vous jure on joue beaucoup
moins angoissés car en effet des progrès
80 au portier bravo valérie de la rue ce
que je les attends bah oui oui les
enjeux là bravo valérie 5000 euros pour
eux non franchement ça valait maintenant
oui ça va mieux ma chérie